back I'll put the power in PowerPoint
today hey guys don't forget a party this
weekend my place bring booze chips and
most importantly yourselves oh I can't
make it on Friday I agreed to help a
friend move and I don't know what I'm
gonna be done yeah I wish I could go too
but my dad's in town I gotta show him
around the old city
you know how dads are sure well bummer
but what about you Quinta oh uh I can't
go either because I don't want to um I'm
sorry uh do you have something to do uh
no I am I just don't want to go uh-huh
do you uh is your dad in town and you
have to take him around the city too
oh no no my dad is living peacefully in
Philadelphia he hasn't visited in years
I just don't wanna go you don't want to
go because it's far away because it's in
Studio City and that's a dry actually
look pretty close to Studio City in the
valley yeah I just don't want to attend
the party
I'm sorry Quinta is this something I did
oh my god Justin no where are you
kidding me you're a dear and you didn't
do anything I just would rather not and
will not be attending your party hold on
is it because you have an improv class
that night that's what it is no that's
actually a three o'clock p.m. in the
afternoon oh but that night you've got
roller derby that's why you can't go
thank you so much for remembering Steve
such a doll but that actually got
cancelled this weekend Quinn Salette me
get this straight
yeah I'm having a party yes and you were
my friend I am and I invited you thank
you but I am NOT going to that party
what are you gonna do instead what is
your reason for not going to his party
Oh
my reason the reason that I am NOT going
to Justin's party is that I do not want
to go to Justin's party hold on let's
figure this out I invited you to a party
which means Quinta goes
right okay let me show you the problem
with your logic there let me get that
matched just a little off so see what
you did here but what you forgot was X
which is I don't want to go which then
changes the outcome - I am NOT going
wait what simple man I get it
Quinta here is trying to pull a fast one
on us she's saying that she's not gonna
go she's gonna show up halfway through
the party and yell surprise it's an
opposite surprise party okay that is a
really fun way to think of it you guys
if the surprise is that I will not be
there because I'm not going come on I'm
having a party and I invited you and
you're just not gonna go because you
don't want to go at least these guys
came up with valid excuses right guys
Steve
if I could be as honest as Quinta I'm
not going because I don't want to go I
[Music]
mean my dad actually is in town and
let's go see the city but I mean if he
wants to go to your party then maybe
hello son oh hey sir would you be
interested in coming to my party no I
don't want to go to your party
[Music]